honey maybe we should just call it a
night you go ahead I gotta finish these
center pieces and rearrange the seating
chart
yes
hello Mom now is not the time I just
want to ask is that genetics or is it
like Pilates
we got your gift it's your Something
Borrowed brings you good luck except for
Uncle Greg who ended up decapitated on
that forklift but that's not the knives
fall oh someone just left it in the
bathroom
[Music]
he forgot to button his shirt all the
way up
is it time for dinner
you look so much better than the rest of
us I think the left boom is slightly
lower than the right food
thing doesn't feel right
[Applause]
here's the plan
spray him in the ice it won't work why
so many steps
that's why you only have a plan with
once
not once did I wonder
if I'd be walking handcuffed Through the
Jungle with a live grenade
oh you got it I got it you got it okay
[Music]
we're gonna fix this
I just growing on me I wanted something
less traditional
nobody with my family
[Music]
[Music]
study your sister
Carol thank you for the cake knife
I freaking love this game